[silence]
>> Stephan: Hi and welcome back to another
VC libraries open code review.
Today we'll be looking at the STL's
favoritest attribute in the whole world.
Nodiscard. We have a PR, umm, from our
contributor Alex Guteniev, number 2211.
Nodiscard messages.
So we've been looking at this, umm,
Which addresses a couple of,
uh, enhancement issues that
we had filed a while ago. Umm,
but first I wanted to give some
background on what is this attribute,
what does the STL use it for,
and what do we want to do in this PR?
Umm, so if you haven't heard of nodiscard
r attributes in general, umm
they're a way to mark things like
functions or data members, but in
this case it's applicable to functions. Umm,
In ways that,
Don't necessarily carry required
semantic meaning for the compiler,
meaning that in theory the attribute
should be ignorable and you should still
get the same behavior you would otherwise.
But sometimes it can help the
compiler emit better codegen,
it can help the compiler emit
better diagnostics,
things like that.
This rule isn't strictly
followed by the standard,
there's things like nouniqueaddress that
do have a bit more of an effect than others.
Nodiscard is very much a classic
attribute where you could ignore every
single nodiscard in the program.
And aside from compiler warnings,
it should have no effect.
But the effect that it
does have is quite useful.
So I can open up.
Let me open up the STL here
locally and if I do a search,
a global search for every
occurrence of nodiscard,
we use a macro in our product
code that is internal to us.
It should not be used by users.
Discard if I can type correctly.
Here we go.
There are
5541 occurrences of this
nodiscard annotation.
In the STL. We use this everywhere,
and in fact we use it much more
than suggested by the standard.
All of this is quality of implementation.
Implementations of the STL are
not required to use nodiscard,
but we love it so much we've put 3000, 4000,
5000 in counting occurrences.
So why do we do this?
Why is it so important to not
discard the results of function?
So some I've seen when talking
to peopl reactions,
to nodiscard are sort of split.
Some people are like, you know,
as soon as they see it, they're like,
oh cool, I should go use this.
And other people are very skeptical,
and it's reasonable to be
skeptical of a new technology,
especially if it increases verbosity.
If you've got a function like say
`[[nodiscard]] int square(int)`,
and that returns a couple N's here,
I can print out the use of square.
And it should print.
There we go once I get the syntax right.
Yeah, so that works fine.
So what nodiscard does is it
diagnoses incorrect uses like
this where you call a function,
it drops the return value on the floor,
which is valid,
but here the compiler will warn because
we marked it as nodiscard warning
C 4834 discarding return value
function with nodiscard attribute.
Which is a reminder to the
programmer that hey,
did you mean to do something with square 5?
Here this function is an example
of what we call a pure observer.
It exists only to take some arguments,
compute some stuff and return it.
So if you drop the return value on the floor,
why did you call the function in the
first place that had no side effects?
So this is the most common reason we
mark things as nodiscard in the STL.
So one of the reasons why we can use
over 5000 occurrences is that as long
as your programs operating properly,
you know you're actually using all the
return thing/return values that we've marked,
You get no warnings.
Um,
as long as we're very careful to apply no
discard
only when we're highly confident that
warnings will indicate actual bugs or,
you know, actual forgotten code,
then we avoid the false positives.
Because users hate false positive warnings.
They're noisy,
they cause people to just
turn off the warning
with a warning disable switch,
that would significantly degrade
the utility of the feature.
So with nodiscard,
we try to strictly apply it to cases
where we're highly confident that
it's going to find actual problems,
and only in a couple of places have
we been a little bit too overeager.
nodiscard have had to pull it back.
It does mean that there are some
cases like unique pointer release
where 90% of discards are a bug but
10% are maybe valid and because that
10% that we don't want to emit noise,
we don't mark the thing as nodiscard
even though it would find bugs,
the cost of false positives is too great.
So maybe this is compelling.
You know seeing this nodiscard saying oh wow
you caught a bug but maybe you're thinking,
OK, how often am I gonna just
call a function, drop its value on
the floor and I wanted it anyways.
You know, how bad could that be?
So let me present the the most compelling
reason that I've seen for nodiscard.
It has found a few bugs
in production code bases,
so let's change this.
Let's have a couple containers.
Let's have the be 10, 20, 30.
`vector two = `.
Let's iterate over both of these
containers simultaneously. So for
`auto i = v1.begin(), auto j = v2.begin();`
the condition,
as long as `i != v1.end()`
comma `j != v2.end();`
and then we want to increment I,
comma increment J and then
we're going to say cout.
We'd like to dereference the iterator.
Nope, can't do that.
deref i. And then a comma.
I see Casey and Nicole are smiling because
they know it's coming. deref J.
And then maybe print a new line.
OK, and let me warning disable 4834.
So we pretend what happens if the STL
does not have nodiscard warnings.
What happens here?
OK, so maybe I'll put a space
here to make it pretty.
So hey, this program compiled, it,
ran, it, worked, everything's good,
right?
I mean,
I got 10 and 40, 20 and 50, 30 and 60 printed.
Well, there is a bug here.
Let's see what the bug is by enabling the nodiscard
warning as it is enabled by default.
And I think,
think, think.
Why am I not getting the nodiscard warning?
We're under latest,
did the thing actually recompile for us?
We totally should have gotten
the warning here. Yeah.
Sometimes I've seen Compiler
Explorer doesn't always recompile.
OK, now I have a mystery because this really,
really should have
emitted the nodiscard warning.
Uh, let's see, we've got iterators.
We are totally ohh. Ohh,
I think I found a compiler limitation here.
It's a good thing we've got
a compiler dev on the call.
OK, so this is interesting.
Let me downgrade us to C++17
because I really want this example.
Then we'll talk about what
I think I just discovered.
OK, everybody's learning
something today, including me.
So it's compiling under 17 mode. Here we go.
OK, so this is the warning I expected to see.
And then in a bit we'll get to
why we didn't see the warning.
So we get a squiggle on line 11,
warning, discarding return value
function with nodiscard attribute.
Oh, that's interesting.
I said I not equal V1 end.
End comma, and I put that
comment in there intentionally.
J not equal V2 End.
This comma is wrong.
The comma here is necessary because you got
to define two variables here. The comma here
is necessary;
it's a comma operator.
We're going to increment both I and J. Here
you do not want a comma because
if you put a comma there,
we ignore the left hand side
because we compare 2 iterators.
We got a bool,
then we drop it on the floor,
and the result of this is only J.
So what we really wanted was operator
and. This is a bug and the reason
why I say this is my favorite
example is we have seen like at
least two or three occurrences
in real production code bases.
I will avoid naming names, where
people ship this to users and the
code was behaving incorrectly and
in this case it misbehaves if the
vectors are ever different lengths.
You want this to end as soon as
one of the two vectors is exhausted
vectors exhausted.
Um, so having a comma there is
a real bug in this case,
it seems seemed to work fine,
but if I had let's see if I
have too many elements,
we would.
end as V2 ends so it would seem to work fine.
But if V1 does not have enough elements,
the and will work properly where
we stop as soon as we consume
the final element 20 of V1.
But the comma will give us
undefined behavior, and it will
be diagnosed in debug mode.
Ohh yeah,
we let's disable the nodiscard
warning 4834 and if we compile in debug
mode we'll get the debug assertion.
Yeah, where you think you think.
Yeah,
it intentionally crashes because
we get our debug check and in
release mode we briefly saw
you get undefined behavior.
But in practice what we get here is garbage.
So there's a real bug if you say
comma and nodiscard catches it
because it gets the library to
communicate information to the compiler.
The compiler just sees a function
call here -- operator not equal.
For a vector int iterator,
which is a class type,
it's reasonable to call a function
and then drop its value on the floor.
That's what happens when you call
printf,
did you know the printf returns an int?
Almost everybody ignores that int
because it's not really useful.
But here we really want this pure
observer not equal to not be discarded,
so nodiscard will find bugs.
You want this enabled.
We do enable it by default,
and ideally point of this code review
is to try to convince you to start
marking your own functions as nodiscard
when they meet the proper criteria.
Yes, it's a little bit of verbosity,
almost always it's not going to find
anything, but when it finds something
you're going to be really glad.
Um, OK, so let's pop the stack here and
let's go back to why we did not see this.
Let's, I think C++ 20 will find the issue.
So in C++20 we've got the comma
here and it's not diagnosing,
so I think this is actually a compiler bug.
I'm going to need to report
this after this video.
Or perhaps one of the STL maintainers here
can report the compiler bug as I talk.
The issue here is that I am calling operator
not equal. In
C++20 mode we got the spaceship operator
and along with the spaceship operator we
got a bunch of cool rules that says that
a class only needs to provide operator equal.
Let me add some comments here.
Op equal and then if you
provide operator spaceship.
Then the equal will be used to generate,
um, not equal.
Or really if you say not
equal it gets rewritten,
I should say rewritten.
So usage of not equal is rewritten
to equal, equal and with
spaceship any usage of less than,
greater,
less equal,
greater equal is rewritten to spaceship.
Umm the there's articles, uh,
that will explain why equal and
spaceship are treated differently.
But the quick answer is that
for some things equality can be
answered faster than a full less
than or greater than comparison.
For example, if you have two
vectors of different lengths,
we can see instantly that they are non
equal by just comparing their lengths.
Whereas if you want to know
is 1 less than the other,
we actually have to look at every element
because if one has the same elements
as another and is simply a prefix or suffix,
then we actually do need to compare all
the elements until we exhaust one of them.
So that's why they can't be fully fully
unified all the time into just spaceship.
But we can always generate.
Or we can always rewrite not equal and equal,
and the STL Now takes advantage
of this in C++ 20 mode.
I can actually dig up the relevant code.
Let's go to vector.
Here we go. Let's look at.
Let's just search for occurrences
of operator equal equal.
So in our internal implementation vector
iterators we have something called underscore
capital vector constant iterator
and another one for modifiable iterators.
We always provide an operator
equal equal in C++20 mode.
Here's our internal macro to indicate that we
also provide a spaceship. In non C++20 mode,
ee then need to provide not equal, less
greater, less equal, greater equal.
But when we're in 20 mode,
all we need is equality and spaceship,
and the rest will be rewritten
to one of these two. So,
going back to why I was momentarily confused.
Um, we have very carefully marked
all of these things as nodiscard
because calling any of these iterator
comparisons is a pure observer,
and if you drop that on the floor well you
probably have a bug like I just showed.
However,
this has shown that if the compiler, if the
user has written, me being the user not equal,
and then the compiler says,
oh, we're in C++20 mode,
I'm going to rewrite that into
equal equal because I see that
operator and this iterator
class did not provide a not equal operator.
When the compiler does that rewriting,
it is not carrying along the nodiscard.
We marked the actual operator
that's being called as nodiscard,
but that bit is being lost
when the rewrite happens.
That should not be the case. For this rewrite,
if the function that's
ultimately called is nodiscard,
then the rewritten call should
absolutely emit a nodiscard warning.
So we should get a warning for that.
I see a new bubble in the chat.
Did we get something?
Here we go.
OK yeah there Casey and Nicole are
asking who should report. Cameron,
our compiler Dev, says can confirm
I have a bucket of Casey bugs and
Nicole reports that GCC exhibits
the same bug but Clang does not.
So we have some compiler variation,
but hopefully in the future all compilers
will properly carry over nodiscards.
So this is actually good to know.
I did not realize that this was language
mode sensitive until I wrote this example.
So,
Casey has 1 argument that it's not
a bug that not X equal equal Y
doesn't discard the result of X equals Y,
But it's really the compiler
should because
the compiler is doing the rewriting so
it can see that the top level invocation
is being discarded, and it really should.
And then yeah, Cameron has an example where…
Oh, interesting.
So I wonder why
why clang handles some of them?
OK, so a little bit more
investigation needed there.
So that's the idea behind nodiscard.
Now let me quickly explain what
this PR is going to look at.
nodiscard was added in C++17
and we are now using that.
In fact,
we use it even in C++14
mode because we have,
Uh, it it's permitted as future
technology where uh features from
future standards are supported.
And C++20 added nodiscard with a reason.
So you can now put a string
literal in nodiscard.
Let's see what that looks like,
with the compiler.
Let me get rid of vector here.
OK, so let me go back to
this example nodiscard.
Uh, pure observer,
n square and int return n * N.
OK, so I cout.
Square 5 and everything is good.
20 mode warnings enabled, it works,
but if I call square 5 all by itself
with the semicolon, what happens?
OK, we get warning now.
The numbers changed 4858.
I think that is different than before
discarding return value, pure observer.
So whatever string literal you put
in this nodiscard gets emitted.
I guess I can try both.
What if we don't have the reason?
What if we were cubing something?
And then we call Cube of 5.
There we go.
OK.
Umm, OK,
yeah,
indeed they are different warning
numbers and we can customize the message
with nodiscard with the message.
So we had filed an issue early
on in the repo's history noting
when this feature was voted in
and one of the todos that we
had in mind was maybe we could
use this in the STL to provide a
little bit more context to users.
So as I mentioned,
we have a few criteria which we've
sort of mentally laid out and we've
explained it like to the Standardization
Committee a few times because the
standard is now marking a few things
as nodiscard which strongly
suggests to implementers that they
do that in their implementation,
although it's not a binding
requirement why you would want
to mark things as nodiscard.
So by far the most common
reason is pure observers,
things that do not have side effects
or they have side effects in very rare
and unusually pathological cases. So,
comparisons,
those are almost always nodiscard.
Another example is like std::find.
std::find takes a range
of elements and a value,
or find if takes a predicate and
looks for the first occurrence of an
element that's equal to the desired one,
or satisfies the predicate and
then returns an iterator to it,
or the end iterator if it
didn't find anything.
That is a pure observer.
And if you call a find and you drop
the value of the iterator on the floor,
you've probably done something wrong.
So you're just spending
cycles when you don't need to.
It is true that either the
comparison could have side effects
because it could go log something,
or go modify something,
or especially the predicate
form could go have side effects
somewhere, even while it upholds the
standard while it's conformant,
as long as it returns consistent
results for the same input,
the standard actually doesn't
care if that predicate has side
effects, but it would be very
unusual to call find only for the
side effects of the predicates.
It doesn't mean it never happens.
In fact, I've seen the
compiler do it once or twice.
Um, but it's very unusual.
So this is not the case where
like 10% of calls are totally
valid and 90% of calls are bugs,
but we care about the 10% we want to
avoid marking things as nodiscard
in the case of like find 99.99% of
invocations that are discarding that
iterator are doing so incorrectly.
And for that point you know 0.0001% that
really do want those side effects,
it's reasonable to ask those users to
silence the warning in a targeted manner.
So applying like /WD4834 or.
WD4858 to silence these
nodiscard warnings.
That's a very large hammer.
You don't want to use that because it
shuts up every single nodiscard warning.
Instead, if you see a nodiscard
warning and you want to silence it,
you can just cast the thing to void.
This will tell the compiler,
hey, you know I really did mean to call
this thing and then just ignore
what it does. Most of the time,
in fact, almost all the time,
this should not be necessary.
But if you ever see a nodiscard
warning that is validly marked
and yet your usage is valid,
put a void cast there.
And if you don't like paren void,
you can also do.
Static cast if you really like this.
Yes, most of the time this happens
in a compiler and library test,
because we're very interested in
writing expressions that we verify
compile, or don't crash the compiler,
but we're not actually
interested in what they do,
so we just drop the value on the floor.
So most of the time it's the actual
library implementers that have
to go add a bunch of void casts,
and we have had to do this in a
bunch of places, but in user code,
unless you have similar sort of tests,
this should almost never be necessary.
OK, so I mentioned,
Pure observer is the most common reason,
but there are other reasons that you would
want to mark something as nodiscard.
So off the top of my head there are
functions that are easily confused.
So vector empty is the classic
one where if you want to,
if you want to get rid of all of,
I'm trying to avoid the words here.
If you want to get rid of
all the elements in a vector,
you might say `V.empty()`,
because empty sounds like a verb.
Unfortunately for the STL,
empty is an adjective and it returns a bool,
so if you call empty and
you drop it on the floor,
you've done nothing rather than
wiping out all your elements.
What you meant to say was `V.clear()`,
so this confusion is so notorious
that the standard itself has
marked vector empty as nodiscard.
I can actually bring that up
if people are interested.
Um, now, for us,
that doesn't actually make a difference,
because, um,
vector empty also falls under
the pure observer criterion,
so we would mark it for that reason alone.
But even if you didn't have, you know,
the willingness to go Mark 3000,
5000 functions in your STL is nodiscard,
the commonly confused case
is a justification.
Let me actually just bring this up
so we can see what it looks like.
Here's vector.
Here's the class definition.
I scroll down a bit.
And I've scrolled too far.
Here we go.
Empty in the standard is
depicted as nodiscard,
a nonbinding suggestion to
implementers that they actually mark it.
So pure observers are commonly confused functions.
Other ones are cases where
dropping the return value on the
floor is likely to be incorrect,
or a memory leak, or a resource leak.
So allocate, raw allocation functions.
Those should totally be marked as
nodiscard because you either need to
store them in a resource management object,
like a unique pointer or something,
or you need to manually ensure
that you deallocate, free,
release, whatever the thing,
and that you don't leak during exceptions.
So at raw resource allocation functions,
those should be marked nodiscard.
And another more obscure case is where
you're not going to leak resources,
but if you discard the results,
you're going to skip some important
second follow-up step that would
make your program incorrect.
So that example there is like
std::remove and std::unique
Where those are
so notoriously confusing,
they had to be an item in Scott
Meyers effective C++ books.
Where the algorithm, um,
sort of compacts the good
elements that you want to retain
at the beginning of the range,
leaves the remaining elements in
some garbage unspecified state,
and then you need to follow that up
with a call to container erase to
actually physically make the container
smaller and get rid of the garbage elements.
So if you say,
std::remove or std::unique,
and then you drop the return value
on the floor, you have a bug,
even though it's not a pure observer
because it's really modifying stuff,
it's not
allocating memory, um,
it is skipping that second step
that you need for correct program.
So that's a case for nodiscard.
So nodiscard with a reason is a
way for the STL to communicate to
users why you would want to do this.
So that's what these issues we're
talking about and that's what
Alex Guteniev has gone and done.
So this has PR been open for a while.
We're now finally getting to review it.
Apologies for the delay.
Let's actually take a look at the code.
OK,
So what Alex is doing here is taking
that macro which we mentioned,
underscore nodiscard,
which is for the STL's internal use,
and replacing selected occurrences
with other macros.
Because oftentimes the message that
we want to give is repeated in a
whole bunch of different places,
like we got std::remove, std::remove_if
ranges, remove ranges,
remove if they all have the same
rationale so we can just use the
same message for all of them and
centralizing that in a macro
is reasonable.
In the future we might make
the message itself a macro and
otherwise use an attribute.
The reason why we're using an attribute
for nodiscard is partially for
historical reasons that we added it
when not all compilers supported it,
that we may be able to change that now,
especially since we like nodiscard
so much and we have not had cases
where users have had needed
to activate the escape hatch.
But for the time being,
putting the whole attribute
in a macro is what we do.
So first I'd like to look at the macros,
make sure that,
um, all of them make sense.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna skip reviewing the actual
grammar of the messages for now.
I'll come back and do that later,
and then we'll see if they're being
applied to all cases properly and
if we're forgetting anything.
And if I could make this highlight go away,
that would be good.
OK,
there we go.
So let's alt click and see
what files are being modified.
So although it looks like 257
lines are being modified,
it's really just a scattering.
This PR is not as large as it seems,
and most of the lines are
yvals_core.h
because it's adding a bunch of messages.
So let's see what messages are being added.
OK, so um, here we go.
yvals_core.h the STL central internal header,
a transition comment because currently
vcruntime is not open sourced.
This should go to vcruntime.h agreed.
So right now Alex is following the pattern.
Ohh I see this was, this is
essentially following the nodiscard
ctor for constructors because
that's a separate feature.
So this looks right. OK,
so transition this should go to vcruntime H.
If the compiler does not
support has CPP attribute,
then nodiscard message of a
message expands to nothing.
Elif has CPP attribute nodiscard
I believe this is the correct
value but let's check.
So if we search for SD feature test
this will bring up the standing
document showing feature test macros.
We're going to look for the
CPP attribute nodiscard.
And let's find wee.
We're gonna skip that.
Here we go. So OK.
The same value of July 2019 is
used for two different papers.
Nodiscard should have a reason
and nodiscard for constructors.
So even though these are different
things that we're testing,
they have the same value.
So 201907 is the correct thing.
I love to double check this because
copy paste errors with feature
test macros are quite possible.
So exact same value, that's good.
So if we don't have it
all expands to nothing.
If or if we don't have the ability to
check CPP attributes expands to nothing.
Otherwise,
if the nodiscard attribute is greater
than or equal to nodiscard message,
then it should expand to
nodiscard with a reason.
Now there is a transition here
that's blocking it for the CUDA
compiler because CUDA 10.1 did
not support nodiscard message.
What has changed fairly recently,
I'm not actually sure if it changed,
I think it changed after Alex
created this PR, but I can check.
That was, the fastest way is actually
in the change because I forget
what file we we modified.
We increased our CUDA requirement to 11.6.0.
That happened fairly recently.
I think it was this PR.
Yes.
Where we updated our CUDA
compiler to the first version
that officially supported VS 2022,
that also updated its front
end and it is now required.
So it did happen far after Alex
originally created this PR.
So we should check if CUDA 11.6.0
supports nodiscard message.
I would hope that it does,
but it might not, because this is a
C++20 feature and supporting
it in lower standard modes,
Umm, actually no.
This should be controlled by
the standard mode.
This gracefully downgrades.
If you have nodiscard,
but you don't have nodiscard message.
Then Alex's machine reads downgrade.
So really this we should not
need to block CUDA CC.
If this works OK, add a comment um.
Uh, number blah um.
Ah.
As 2791 updated to CUDA 11.6.
Is this um block still?
Or do we still need to block?
The less special casing the better.
OK, as 2791 updated CUDA 11.6,
do we still need to block CUDA here?
OK. And that is definitely on us.
For not getting around to reviewing
this earlier we've been slowly
getting through the uh the PR backlog.
OK reloading everything.
[unintelligible], transition this go to vcruntim H we
don't have CPP attribute detection
at all, that expands nothing.
ELIF nodiscard is greater than or
equal to the nodiscard message
version and ask about the CUDA
block not to find CUDA CC OK,
then expand to actually use it.
Otherwise if the nodiscard attribute
is at least the classic value, and
I think this is right,
but let's double check.
Yes, 201603 is the original value.
Correct, greater equal then use it by itself,
otherwise expand to nothing.
And because the control regions here are
pretty tiny and it's not heavily nested,
we don't demand comments here, OK.
So this is. Ah, OK,
so that's nodiscard message and then,
Alex is adding a variant attribute
for nodiscard constructor message
because sometimes we may want to
mark constructor with a reason.
So if we don't have the attribute,
if we can't look for attributes at all,
expand to nothing. If we have both
the constructor and the reason,
then nodiscard ctor expands to the
one without a reason nodiscard ctor
message expands to nodiscard message.
Otherwise,
this is the case where it is not
sufficiently new for the constructor,
so we have no possible fall back.
They expand to nothing.
Agreed, and two lines are controlled here.
This is still OK to not have a comment.
And here we do not,
we can't unify the macros because
if we just use nodiscard message,
it would degrade to double
bracket nodiscard.
But that cannot appear in such old
modes or old compilers on a constructor.
So this macro is necessary
assuming it's still being used,
and I think it is.
One thing I like to check for is
if a PR has been heavily revised,
make sure that all of the machinery
it's still adding, the need for it
has not disappeared during edit.
So I'm going to expand everything,
search for uses. Here's the definition.
OK, so nodiscard,
ctor lock and nodiscard
ctor thread are using it.
Like ignoring a thread.
OK, it is being used. Good.
So this is not stale in any way.
Excellent.
OK, so that's nodiscard message
and nodiscard ctor message.
So now I'm going to look at the macros
that are being added to understand if these
are good cases to emit the warning,
why we're getting the warning there or why
in this case, I think this
PR is converting every everyone
already had a nodiscard to reason,
so we just need to make sure the reason
is unique enough to deserve a message.
And think about are there any cases that
are not obvious that should also be marked?
So as I mentioned,
the remove algorithms,
those are a classic example where they
have a second step that needs to be done.
So this is definitely good.
The unique algorithms,
same idea but a different name.
This is sufficiently different enough
that I think having a separate macro we
could super unify it into like remove unique.
I suppose one could do that. But here,
just looking at the message briefly,
there's a good reason Alex has got
a good reason for splitting these,
because with remove he suggests using
the erase and erase_if functions that I
added to the standard originally in a TS.
But that's not applicable to unique.
There's no unique-ifying thing that will
also sort. So that is sufficient
reason to not super unify all of this.
OK, next is empty member function.
Although this does fall under
our pure observer criterion,
this is a very likely bug that new
users could commit when you're just
using vector for the first time.
And although experienced users will
understand what happens when they drop,
like, you know,
operate not equal on the floor
or something empty versus clear.
Providing the guidance to call
clear is reasonable,
and there's only a few occurrences,
so having a dedicated message is
reasonable. Also because the standard
thought it was important enough to mark.
Um, OK, next?
Empty on an array.
Um, that's a pure observer,
but there's no such thing as clear,
so providing guidance for clear
would be wrong.
So have special special casing this for array
also seems reasonable.
It could be argued that
the user might think that this
is more of a pure observer case,
but I could see a user converting
from like vector to array if they're
not really familiar with the two and
then thinking they could empty it out,
and having the separate guidance
here seems reasonable. OK.
OK, so it looks like Alex is adding
messages for everything named empty.
There's one in stacktrace, which is
the feature Alex himself implemented.
This explains how to clear the stack trace.
I like this one because since
I use vector all the time,
I'm like everything behaves like a vector.
I don't need to know any other class,
and I might, you know, if I'm not sufficiently
caffeinated, say `stacktrace.empty()`.
Having guidance that explains what to
do and how to reassign it is reasonable.
And then it looks like Alex just
has a fall back empty function,
but not, doesn't need specific guidance
for clear. This seems reasonable.
Can any, this is sufficiently vague.
Container, container like object?
That seems right.
_EMPTY_MEM_FN_ADAPTER.
Ah, for queues and stacks,
I was like _EMPTY_MEM_FN,
but I thought that that function
doesn't have any sort of empty.
But no, it's a empty on, an empty
member function on an adapter.
Now I'm currently thinking do I like
_EMPTY_MEM_FN here, eh it's not
really a problem for searching because
the actual function is lower case.
_EMPTY_MEM_FN.
Yeah it's not worth trying to rename.
OK yeah queue or stack and agreed
that there's no way to clear.
I'll like I mentioned later
I'll do a check for spelling and
stuff because that needs to be
fixed so these all seem good.
Next up barrier.
So this is the multithreading.
New multithreading component.
If you arrive at a barrier,
you should not discard that token.
You're going to need it.
You're going to need to wait.
This is excellent because if you're
new to barrier you might not
realize I didn't remember this case,
that we marked this as nodiscard
for an unusual reason.
This is a case kind of like removing
unique that it's a multi step thing.
Um try wait.
OK, so here I guess we had we had
marked it as nodiscard. And if you,
tried to wait for something,
you would probably want to know what
happened, like did you success?
Did you reach this success
criterion or did did it time out?
So you really should inspect it.
I remember there were some, there
were some controversy slash
question about there was some,
I'm trying to remember what it was
in condition variable or something.
There's like a member function where we
really, it was like unique pointer remove
ehrtr we wanted to mark it as nodiscard,
but users came up with some cases that
were like 10% reasonable 10% of the
time and we ultimately did not mark it.
I can't remember it was that try
wait or was that something else?
Something like that I guess I can search.
It's been a few years.
>> Nicole: My understanding is that try wait like.
Immediately returns you like,
I don't think that there is any
reason to call it except to
check if something is finished.
>> Stephan: Ohh it's like instant.
It doesn't take a chrono or something
>> Nicole: Right, that that's my understanding anyways.
I very well could be wrong.
>> Stephan: Oh oh cause it's it's latch.
Latch is try waited.
It just returns a bool.
OK, I was thinking of wait for and
wait for until. OK yeah you're right.
So in fact let's check wait for.
Uh, let's see. That's future.
That's ugly.
I don't want ugly.
Ah, here we go.
So, like in condition variable,
are we in the normal condition variable here?
Condition variable any we've got wait for, it
returns a CV status.
You probably should be checking this thing,
but there's a few cases where
it's reasonable not to,
so we did not mark this as nodiscard.
Um, but you're right that
try wait is special,
and we already marked it as nodiscard,
so this is just providing a reason.
Excellent. Um, OK. Great.
Um, _TRY_CHANGE_STATE.
What even is a _TRY_CHANGE_STATE?
Interesting.
This must be. This must be used on
things that are not literally named
_TRY_CHANGE_STATE.
I would just like to see what
it is and then I'll resume.
>> Casey: Search for the macro.
>> Stephan: Yeah ohh try_lock OK.
Try like for try_lock until OK.
OK, that seems sufficiently generic.
OK, let me go back.
If I change state, um.
_TRY_CHANGE_STATE_FN.
Non member versus member.
Here it's, these are really similar
as, is this the first pair that
was member versus non member?
I think it is every everything
else here was like member yeah
remov and unique are nonmembers
for the ones we care about.
Empty is always a member function.
Barrier is a member function.
Try wait is member function.
So these are the first ones that are
free versus member function pair.
>> Nicole: I believe that empty has two,
one for member function and one for the
like std::empty of a container.
>> Stephan: Oh, oh, yeah, because we have.
Uh, yeah, you're right.
Yeah, like, like size and um.
_EMPTY_MEM_FN.
Ohh, empty function. Ah yes.
Good catch. Yep, there it is.
Yeah, non member. OK, so yeah,
it's reasonable to have one for _TRY_CHANGE_STATE
and _TRY_CHANGE_STATE_FN
Ah.
>> Nicole: It would be nice if the
things were standardized so that,
like the member function
one is always underscore,
memb under_score.
>> Stephan: Yeah yeah,
>> Nicole: the function one is always _fn.
>> Stephan: Yeah, at least in the case
where we have both.
And this this one actually spells
out function. Empty function,
_EMPTY_MEM_FN. I suppose when we I,
I like having the different spelling
function because that way one is not a,
um, like strict substring of the other.
But I agree that it should
be consistently done.
That's worth a comment. OK, so.
>> Nicole: That I have a concern with calling it
function just because that sounds like
a very common thing,
and I think that function has an empty
member variable or member function.
>> Stephan: Ohh std function understood.
Function does not.
It has just an operator
explicit operator bool.
You're right that it is a very
common word, unfortunately.
Standard doesn't quite say
free function anywhere.
It just says nonmember but
nonmember fn or something.
Seems very verbose.
Let's see. Any any ideas?
There's, um, let's see the
>> Nicole: mem fn without a thing,
and then just fn, so you could search for like
FN with a underscore before it.
Versus mem fn.
>> Stephan: We we could do that, I'm thinking.
Where is the calling convention thing?
Um. It's a non member.
Every case. Uh, OK, let's search
for all occurrences of std call.
No, that's gonna be horrible fast call.
There we go. That's the next to def.
Why did I miss it? Ohh, it's emit.
Ah, OK, so we have it.
Nonmember call for these horrible
macros and then member call.
So that's the precedent
where we have to distinguish
members versus nonmembers.
We spell out member and
then we say non member.
So for these macros,
let me go back to the review.
If we followed that convention,
which I'm not necessarily saying
is a great convention because
those macros are horrible,
it would be something like empty non
member versus empty member adapter.
Member is more common here, but non
member is more common elsewhere like well.
Now actually I would say all of the
cases where we have both, the member
ones more common because we have a
lot of member functions then just
one non Member function to mention.
So how do you feel about like
non member versus member and
just not saying function at all?
>> Nicole: Seems reasonable to me,
especially because nodiscard
is not getting applied to like.
Member data or whatever.
>> Stephan: Right.
OK, I'll add a comment there.
Let's see where to mention it.
Yeah, seems reasonable.
So remove alg, unique alg,
_EMPTY_MEM_FN.
Let's see. We should, uh,
consistently mark these. Let's see?
When there are both member and non member
versions of these macros,
we should have a consistent naming
convention for them. Currently,
there's, ah, some variation.
Example variation is:
Nodiscard empty function. Is the.
Versus I'll just get that plain
member versus non member.
But, and then the other one was
_TRY_CHANGE_STATE versus fn. Yeah.
I want to think thoughts that
are bigger than three lines.
Compared to:
_TRY_CHANGE_STATE_FN,
this is the non member,
versus change state.
OK. Let's see if I can quote.
Let's say I didn't open it
locally or open it in the repo.
Let me close some of this stuff.
OK, what's that? OK, let's open up,
the dreaded header xstddef where
mortals fear to tread because
calling conventions are horrible.
Let's see fast call.
Smallest thing that I can quote here.
I guess I could quote individual
lines, I suppose. The non member call.
Versus the member call.
You're saying: Member versus non member,
would be reasonable. Umm.
Also avoiding, um, possible confusion with
std function, as Nicole mentioned,
One
precedent. OK, let's see how this looks.
When there are both member and non
member versions of these macros,
we should have a consistent
naming convention for them.
Currently there's some variation no
discard empty function versus no
discard _EMPTY_MEM_FN compared to no
discard _TRY_CHANGE_STATE_FN versus
nodiscard _TRY_CHANGE_STATE member.
Using capital member versus non
capital member would be reasonable.
Also avoiding possible confusion
with std function, as Nicole
observed, and with std mem fun as I
briefly thought and consistent with
precedent here quoting non member
call and member call. OK.
Right. OK, so I was at
_TRY_CHANGE_STATE.
>> Nicole: It might be also useful if you go back.
Um. Personally I would appreciate if
we had empty array member as opposed
to empty member array. I think.
>> Stephan: I agree that is quite reasonable. Um.
Trying to think all possible
permutations for reminding me of the
recent XKCD comic about tetherballs,
rope versus pole versus ball.
Which orders are most fun, in this case.
Noiscard array member empty.
Because you could say the class
name kind of like, you know,
array, double quote, empty. Um.
So you suggested what empty array member?
I agree that putting member, array member
sounds better than member array.
>> Nicole: Yeah, that's what I suggested.
>> Stephan: So there's empty array member.
Or array member empty.
Beginning with the prefix nodiscard
empty even though it doesn't quite follow
the order of like declaration where you
would say `array::empty`.
This keeps all the empty, they sort together.
>> Nicole: Yeah
>> Stephan: I think that is good, yeah OK.
Let's see, I'll add that here.
Cause it's really just the naming.
Can you again? Yeah, that.
Additionally recommends, and I agree that.
OK, so underscore nodiscard empty.
And then array member would um.
The. Easier to read than no
discard empty member array.
While still having all of the
empty macro sorts together
because we love sorting.
OK, let's see why is this,
like almost truncated
here. Nicole additionally recommends
and I agree that nodiscard empty
array member would be easier to read
than nodiscard empty member array.
While still having all of the
empty macros sort together.
OK, _TRY_CHANGE_STATE. _TRY_CHANGE_STATE_FN.
Nodiscard pointer alloc fn.
This function construction
object wrapped by a pointer.
Versus a raw pointer?
What is the difference between these two?
Pointer alloc? And pointer raw alloc.
Oh, raw alloc, raw alloc does not construct.
And alloc constructs.
Or alloc returns like a smart pointer.
I'm curious about the difference here.
Use this make exception pointer.
So this is resource managed.
It's not gonna leak,
but it makes no sense to call
it and drop it on the floor.
Um make shared?
It seems reasonable to have
a dedicated one for this.
Um, in theory the the construction
of the object would, could have
side effects, but then why are
you dynamically allocating it?
That's interesting.
Cameron reports in the the chat that
he's just fixed the computer bug
preventing nodiscard in C++20.
Thank you Cameron, that is awesome.
OK, so then raw alloc.
This one I assume applies to
something like std allocator
and scoped allocator. Yes.
And memory resource doesn't directly
provide allocator, right? It's um.
Or should we be expecting to see
`polymorphic_allocator` pop up on this scan?
Why is `polymorphic_allocator` not here?
Trying to remember like all the
stuff we've added to the standard.
OK, who says allocate?
It's gonna have a lot of stuff.
Who says pointer allocate?
Um, interesting?
Memory resource.
Do you have a `polymorphic_allocator`?
No. There's a subheader now.
>> Casey: `xpolymorphic_allocator`.
>> Stephan: It's `polymorphic_allocator`?
>> Casey: Yeah, it should be it's own header.
>> Stephan: We have something called allocate.
Uh PMR memory resource has an
allocate that returns a void.*.
It's marked as nodiscard,
but this really should deserve a reason.
Because it's absolutely falling under the,
I'm allocating something wrong,
and I don't think `xpolymorphic_allocator`
is being marked here. Um, check.
No occurrence of `xpolymorphic_allocator`.
OK, so we've got a missing thing.
It's a good thing I'm reviewing all this.
That's a raw pointer one,
because it is a void.*.
OK, so let's quote that.
Go back. `xpolymorphic_allocator`.
Allocate paren, here we go.
Is that the only occurrence here
says void.*? Sorry for that.
If that sound is being captured, here we go.
OK, that's the only occurence here.
Hit y to get a permalink?
Do I want to show that it's memory resource?
Sure.
OK. And Umm, `polymorphic_allocator`?
Where does that allocate come from?
I'll check that in a second.
Let's see. Probably should quote the whole thing.
This should be applied to
`memory_resource::allocate`.
Yes, because it's a raw pointer.
OK, so where does the actual polymorphic
allocator class live?
>> Casey: Same file.
206 I think is what you want.
>> Stephan: Alright, press X, up, we're there.
Ohh yeah, um, this returns a _Ty*.
Equally wrong, yeah.
So this one should also be annotated.
OK, let's get that.
Back here. To 206 allocator,
allocate this one.
What I really want is the ability to
like quote but then hide lines in the
center with like a little expand-y.
So I don't need to do 2 separate quotes,
I'm just going to quote one
`polymorphic_allocator::allocate`.
And polymorphic.
Mighty Morphin allocators allocate.
OK, this should be applied to
memory resource allocate and
`polymorphic_allocator::allocate`.
Really, um, one of the things I
like to do is think about like
all the ways to search the STL,
because like a lot of the things
I do are powered by searching
for every occurrence of a thing,
and that's how I learned the STL originally,
and I still rely on it a lot.
In this case,
our internal macro CRT guard overflow
is something that we use to tell
the compiler that we're going to
internally do a multiplication here,
in this case bytes times number of objects.
And this tells the compiler
to do something very useful,
although slightly nonstandard,
that if an integer
overflow / wrap around happens before
the function is even called,
then that should send, instead of
the actual result of the allocation,
it should send negative
one.
You know the maximum value of
size T to the function so that
the function can see that, oh,
you just try to allocate a zillion bytes,
I should fail.
This catches cases where somebody
tries to allocate something and
they have an integer overflow in
the expression passed to allocate.
That is extremely likely to be a
security bug, and it justifies
doing something very slightly
nonstandard and detecting that bogus
code before they call allocate.
And it has to be a special declspec
annotation on the parameter,
because otherwise there's no
way for the library to influence
what happens before you call it.
So let's search for all occurences for
security guard overflow.
Casey is beating me to the punch
and finding cases where users
don't directly use stuff.
So unfortunately this, also what
we've also marked this that the
compiler teams request on a whole
bunch of things that internally
call allocate pretty soon.
These are not raw functions,
so they should not be,
not marked,
but anything that mentions allocate should.
So let's just take a look.
Regex search for anything that says
hopefully it should be on the same line
and not wrapped: allocate.*.
OK, much fewer occurrences.
So we've got CRT allocator.
That's an internal type Casey mentioned.
Users don't directly call this,
so we mark it as nodiscard for our purposes,
but we don't need to provide
messages, because if this occurs
we're going to know what happened.
Scope allocator I believe was
already addressed by the PR.
Let me split these real quick.
You go on the left, you go on the right.
OK, let's journey over to scoped allocator.
Yes,
pointer allocate and allocate with
hint are being marked as raw alloc,
so that is done. This is,
I wish I had more monitor with, um
>> Casey: Allocator traits.
>> Stephan: This is, yeah,
allocator traits the wrapper in X memory.
Memory. So we've got. See who is this?
Or are these the allocator
traits up here? I want to see the
context, this is std allocator.
Interesting. Allocator traits on
546 should really be marked too,
because it's wrapping the allocator.
It happens to say pointer
rather than _Ty.*, but.
If al-allocate like you should not,
call allocator traits and then drop
it on the floor. That's equally raw.
OK, so this is the missing occurrence.
We should comment this right now. Um.
Let's say it's allocate, allocate at least,
and then allocate with hint, right?
Yeah, because the wrapper here,
let me maximize this quick.
It's allocate, allocate with hint.
We have a allocator traits for
allocate at least? No, we don't.
That's interesting.
So it's only allocated and allocate
with hint.
OK.
Um, should I quote let's quote um X memory?
First occurrence of allocate paren
the space before. OK, normal allocator
traits allocate allocate with hint.
Phase two I want permalink.
OK, I don't need this anymore.
OK. Maximize um. Allocator traits
allocate should also be marked.
Yeah, nodiscard.
It's possible that these were missed
because nodiscard was wrapped on
a different line than allocate.
I'm not exactly sure how Alex found
all these occurrences, but I could
easily see this defeating a search.
I know I've been defeated many way,
many times by things wrapping and I expected
the regex to get them on the same line.
In this case, nodiscard and allocate,
we're on the same line.
OK. So those those two.
OK, we were searching for
all occurrences of allocate.
So that is traits and traits.
And these are the default allocator traits.
Oh, on 6, oh I should also quote this one.
Um 632 and 646.
And it's not actually allocator traits.
This one is what we have these
two specializations for
compiler throughput because
allocator traits ask,
it asks a lot of expensive questions.
If we know it's the default allocator,
we can short circuit a
lot of that SFINAE like here.
This is asking, do you have a pointer type?
Do you have a constant pointer type?
Do you have propagate on container copy?
And if we're allocator
traits for std allocator,
we know the answers to all these questions.
We don't have to ask the
compiler to do all that work.
So let's search for following
occurrences of allocate,
run with the space.
And here we go.
Default allocator traits allocate
and deallocate.
These are kind of widely separated,
but I know GitHub will at least
abbreviate this when it's a bunch.
Default allocator traits.
I'll mention both and back to blah.
Double colon allocation must be marked. OK.
These are all occurring before line
800 something blah blah and blah blah.
OK. So that's those.
Go back to the search.
We're going to want that open again.
OK, so this is the default allocator.
Allocator traits mentioned and mentioned,
and then finally the std allocator one.
These are the ones being marked.
On the left here. OK, so these
are definitely. Oops. Go away.
Default allocator traits. I wanted,
I wanted Alex's PR here.
Yeah, 1, 2, 3 for the std allocator itself.
That's 1, 2. And then the third one,
why did this evade my search?
Because the CRT guard overflow
wrap to the next line. So yes,
you got all the ones in std allocate.
That's good, or std allocator.
And then the last ones were
the ones we mentioned allocate.
The memory resource allocated on
the polymorphic and ooh hello
you were hiding allocate object.
OK, the compiler,
the standard just keeps adding stuff.
I, I forgot about this,
that this this was the thing.
This should also be annotated too,
because we're definitely
allocating a bunch of bytes.
And we get the size of the object.
Yeah, that's ohh,
and it's specific to C++20,
so let's go update that quote.
Um, back to X polymorphic.
Perfect allocator, allocator object.
Yeah.
That was I think, on
yvals that I commented. Yes.
`polymorhpic_allocator::allocate`
and copy paste.
Hopefully this is correct.
I'm saying polymorphic
allocator allocate object.
That is correct spelling there.
And you are indeed.
I'm not getting confused that
allocate object is still a member
of `polymorhpic_allocator`. It is OK.
Good update comments so I don't lose it.
OK, so we are almost done
scanning for all allocates.
We got all three there, and then the
TZDB one is just the CRT allocator.
OK, so that gets all the allocates,
which is good.
That answers the question where
the `polymorhpic_allocator` go.
Go away, OK now.
Assume aligned.
So these are the, UM,
the fun compiler wrapper functions.
If you, say,
assume a line on a pointer that by itself
does not have interesting side effects,
you actually have to use
the thing it returns.
So that is an unusual
reason to mark something
nodiscard.
So message is good.
Launder the even more obscure
standard library function.
Again, only the return value
is specifically laundered.
The original one is still dirty,
so you don't want to use it.
That's good.
Now nodiscard lock suppress.
Just an escape hatch.
What is this?
OK. So Alex is introducing an escape hatch.
For nodiscard lock and nodiscard
ctor lock. That's reasonable.
Previously, we didn't have an escape hatch,
and we just told users that if they they
tried to do this unusual thing, I guess.
I guess I can sketch it out.
So one example where you can write unusual
code, which is technically cromulent,
you could say something like instead of.
What is it? Mutex? No, it's lock guard.
So if you have a global scope like a
mutex mute, and then you say lock guard.
Guard. my guard mute.
Then you can do Cool lock stuff.
Do cool stuff and then when it's destroyed.
This is not that language.
Uh. When it is destroyed,
the lock guard is destroyed.
So this you can do if you name it.
We marked all of the lock guards in the
STL as either nodiscard on the type,
or if they have multiple constructors,
some of which should be nodiscard,
we mark it on the constructors so
that if you accidentally say this,
which constructs a temporary and then
drops it on the floor immediately,
that is dangerous because you are
not actually locked when you do this.
You've destroyed it at the semicolon.
So that is a very,
very important thing to mark. That
catches a whole bunch of bugs.
However, it can occasionally be used validly.
That's if somebody writes something
like this. Comma do cool stuff.
Awesome stuff semicolon.
This constructs a temporary,
suspends it in midair,
does a bunch of other stuff through
common expressions,
and then at the end of the full expression
or the semicolon in ordinary human speak,
the temporaries are destroyed.
Nicole asked.
Doesn't that create a default
constructed lock guard named Mute?
Let me think on.
With uh there, I think the answer
is different for braces or parens.
I always get this wrong. By itself
one case will do that.
I think with parens it doesn't.
It does. Lock guard with parens.
I want to say this one.
Actually creates the default
constructed one named mute.
This one constructs the temporary,
but I'm not 100% certain we can
actually check on Compiler Explorer.
Open up godbolt.org
>> Casey: On the common expression,
it can't be a declaration anyway,
so it should yes, be fine,
>> Stephan: but Nicole was asking about the,
the the case where it's just by itself,
which I've very briefly depicted.
So that's the difference between
if you've got a mutex mute,
and then you have a lock guard.
paren guard one versus lock guard.
brace guard 2. OK, what happens on 20, um?
6 cannot deduce.
But let's just provide mutex here so we
don't have to deal with thinking about CTAD.
Custom template deduction. Mutex.
No, that's not a thing.
There we go.
OK, um, six.
OK,
so six is trying to default
construct, let me comment this out.
Yes, so this. This parentheses are
essentially not doing anything here.
They're wrapping the name of
the variable in parentheses.
So this is not constructing a temporary,
it's trying to construct a name
variable with no arguments,
and here it's complaining there
is no default constructor.
So you're right.
But with braces, this does construct
a temporary and throw it away and.
We get um here by my.
Why am I getting undeclared
identifier needs to be called.
>> Nicole: It needs to be lock,
guard, mutex,
mute as opposed to guard 2.
>> Stephan: Lock guard mutex. Ohh.
That's right. Duh. Thank you.
Try to construct from mute.
Um, here we go.
Yeah, discarding return value.
So this one makes a temporary and
then does nothing with it because we
forgot to say guard with parentheses.
If you tried this,
this would really be redeclaring a variable.
If mute is already around in the same scope.
Redefinition basically different basic types.
But if this were global scope,
you could get away with this.
And there we go.
No appropriate default constructor.
OK, so our reason to use braces.
And so essentially what Alex is doing
here is, we had very intentionally
said we're just going to mark these
constructors and if you try to do the
fancy thing with comma expressions,
well, don't be so clever.
And it, it is reasonable to have a
escape macro here in case you really do
want to suppress the warning on those,
but without having to refactor
code as long as it's enabled.
As long as the nodiscard warning for
the guards is enabled by default,
I have no objection to the
escape hatch here.
Essentially,
if that lets people enable
nodiscard for most of the time
and write their unusual code,
then that's reasonable.
OK, so if def nodiscard locks suppress,
we might want to rephrase that message,
but just the existence of the macro is fine,
expand to nothing. Otherwise,
nodiscard lock and nodiscard ctor lock. OK.
Uh, then we have ones about,
um, these are for constructors.
Thread or if you create a thread
and then just drop it on the floor,
you never joined or detached it.
Well, that's bad.
It's going to terminate with J thread.
That's interesting.
Do we mark J thread ctor as
nodiscard?
It is unusual to construct a J
thread and then do nothing with it.
Let's see.
J thread. OK, we did in fact mark J
thread ctor as nodiscard ctor.
So Alex is simply providing a reason here,
and it does seem reasonable that
you spin up a thread and then
immediately join at the end.
Why did you bother making a whole
thread there when you were going to
do anything else simultaneously?
Very unusual.
Probably wanted to wait until the
end of a scope and then join.
Yeah, so that's reasonable to have.
Async famously also has the blocking.
Yep. And getting a future, if
you get and then discard, yes.
OK, so these are all reasonable to have.
OK, so I like the existence
of all these messages.
And. We found the I think the allocate
one was the case where we really
needed to do an audit of the STL
and find all of the occurrences.
I'm not as worried about the other ones.
I'll, I'll go review this later and make
sure we're not missing anything obvious,
but from a brief glance we're getting like
all the remove, all the unique, and so forth.
So overall the direction
of the PR seems right.
And I don't think we're missing anything.
I'm trying to trying to rack my brain.
Are there other cases where we had
definitely applied nodiscard,
but we didn't provide a reason and
we could provide a reason now.
And this is getting all the ones, in fact,
several ones that I did not think of.
So it's great that Alex has done this,
getting all the cases where the reason
for nodiscard was far from obvious.
The other nice thing is that,
umm, we talked to Alex earlier.
This PR originally tried to add reasons,
I think for a lot of pure observers.
That ended up being very verbose.
It changed a zillion lines most of the time.
The reason for nodiscarding
something is that it's a pure observer
and it's not very surprising,
except for like the empty case
like we discussed,
where if you call you know std fine,
you drop it on the floor,
you get the nodiscard warning.
They're pretty self-explanatory we feel.
So using the plain nodiscard
for the vast majority of cases.
And then using the special macros
for the cases where it's unusual.
It seems to be reasonable for warnings
that do not get admitted that often
they only get admitted under you know,
unusual circumstances and then we
just need to ask OK is the user
going to be confused why they're
getting nodiscard here?
And the non pure preserver cases are the ones
where it seems reasonable to have the macro.
So I'd like the direction of this PR.
I will come back to it after this, and
check all the grammar and make sure
that we're not missing anything else.
But.
I think this is good,
so I'm going to hold off on
submitting this review,
but hopefully we are able to explore
the reasons for nodiscard and why
you should use it in your own code.
Especially like even if you're
just maintaining an application.
nodiscard is useful because everything
defines functions and calls it.
But especially especially if you're
maintaining a third party library,
you should be using nodiscard
as much as the STL.
We are not only putting on all
of our public functions now,
we're going back and adding it to
internal machinery as we update it,
because in our own code we might
forget to call something.
Um, and it's so easy to add,
has essentially no cost to the compiler.
Um, because it's just an attribute.
It can, you know,
digest that token very quickly.
It sets a bit somewhere.
Saying, hey, you know,
if I ever see this, nodiscard,
if I ever see this discarded,
I should have made a warning,
but otherwise it has no,
you know, interesting costs,
especially the one that
doesn't have a message at all.
That's just, you know,
double bracket nodiscard.
Very easy for the compiler to parse that,
so we recommend using it as much as possible.
OK, let me go through the chat,
see if there's any remaining questions.
Let's see, we talked about the, the
bug the Cameron has already fixed.
Casey advises please use views
take while instead of hacking find
with a side effecting predicate.
That is like take elements from
this view until some condition is
met and that condition could be
state accumulated in the predicate.
Is that correct or the function object?
>> Casey: I don't really recommend stateful
function objects,
but if you're using find right you're
going if you're using find and you're
hacking it with a side effecting predicate,
your goal is to change every
element up to the first one found
that satisfies some condition,
right?
So you should pull out some
condition into a predicate,
use that with use take while and
now you have a range of exactly
the elements that you, you know,
wanted to modify and you can use that
instead of this weird hacked find thing.
>> Stephan: Yeah, and I think I've only seen
one or two occurrences of that.
In the the compiler itself.
But yeah,
that does seem like good advice.
>> Casey: The much clearer expression
of programming intent.
>> Stephan: Yeah,
just just write what you mean rather
than sort of mingling the STL into
something that does what you want.
But the reason we have named algorithms
is that you can see the name and you
have some idea of what to expect if
you get a find that's doing fancy,
unusual, side effect-y things you
probably shouldn't be in the find in the first place.
I'm checking the chat for anything else.
Hi Casey's Kitty.
Uh, let's see.
Uh,
let's see.
Nicole does not like the name
allocated object because it only
allocates storage for objects,
not actual objects.
Yeah,
that's a reasonable concern.
Let's see. Oh, interesting that
internal tools are available,
but it's not available to the public.
Then I won't mention that you're all here.
And Casey mentions we're up to 5430
uses of nodiscard in STL headers.
Funny thing, nodiscard is still
going to be more popular than export.
I only have about 3000 occurrences of
export in standard library modules,
and that's because we not only
nodiscard internal functions,
but member functions.
And export does not need to be
applied to every member function,
it only needs to be applied
to top level classes.
So now and forever nodiscard
will be the most popular thing.
And oh, Cameron's already got a PR out
fixing the bug, so that's awesome.
Thank you, Cameron.
OK, I think we can end this review.
Thanks for watching and we'll see
you next time on the VC Libraries
Open code review.